Dean oui Padre quand tu vas
devenir un
rock gagne un million pour qu'ils puissent payer mon
nouvel abri peut-être que tu devrais penser à
revenir dans ta musique adolescent un
DJ paralysé c'est un thé délicieux
bien regarde ce que le chat a roulé  et
vous auriez un vrai DJ ici c'est
le moment où vous devez croire que plus de
92 pensent vraiment que vous allez vous lever et
marcher un jour en ce moment vous
croyez vraiment que oui je fais Brenda nous jugeons la
fièvre quelque chose de nouveau ce que tu fais  tu
me soulèves j'ai la touche de guérison je
n'ai rien à faire me voir ce n'est pas
possible il est possible que
ce soit arrivé que suis-je censé faire faire le tour de
toucher les gens y chapeau
je pense que son enfant a été gardé mon nom est-ce
que c'est  ma vocation cet homme est un artiste
tu verras que le monstre du spectacle peut faire partie de
ta vocation est d'utiliser les deux
ensemble
toi
quelque chose de miraculeux a été ici
c'est la meilleure chose que nous ayons entendue toute la
nuit
je sais comment le rendre réel toi
prêt c'était une rock star
c'est une mousse c'est  un imbécile
pensez-vous vraiment que je pourrais être tout à fait
possible